this right here is the world's most
powerful portable gaming laptop now I
want to emphasize on the word portable
because obviously there's much better
gaming laptops out there but we recently
compared this laptop which is the 20/20
razor blade stealth 13-inch to Apple's
20/20 macbook pro and we found that it
actually does quite well comparing
against it in basically everything
overall including the keyboards the
track pads it's actually very impressive
and if you guys haven't seen that video
yet you can definitely check it out
after this video is over but what makes
this laptop special is that it packs
Nvidia's GTX 1650 Ti max-q graphics card
so it packs a lot of power but before we
get into the gaming I'm gonna close this
down and I'm actually gonna do a couple
of benchmarks all right so we've got
Geekbench v open right here I'm gonna do
the compute
benchmark I'm selecting CUDA and we got
our 1650 Ti 42,000 CUDA score so this
graphic score is insane because we got
about 10,000 on the $1,800 MacBook Pro
now let's go ahead and turn on the unit
in heaven gaming benchmark and here we
go we got a results 45.8 FPS in the
Unison heaven' benchmark extreme preset
that is really really impressive because
with our six inch MacBook Pro I think we
got around the same score maybe even
lower on the huge 16 inch MacBook Pro
with the dedicated 5300 M graphics so
this actually compares very well to the
13-inch MacBook Pro which only got 13.5
FPS and one thing I want to mention
before we get into the gaming is that
the new i7 10th gen processor what's
nice about it is that it's using the new
technology 10 nanometers so it's going
to be more efficient and it's gonna use
less power and that's gonna allow the
graphics to get more power during gaming
so let's get right into it alright so
here we are in warzone let's go through
the settings real quick so we've got the
render resolution set to 1080p unlimited
framerate we've got normal resolution on
the textures I've turned down the
particle quality down to low I've turned
down the shadows anti-alias
is off so we're gonna see how much FPS
we get at these settings with the
texture set to normal all right so we're
sitting at about 59 FPS right now 62 64
actually decent it feels very smooth
right now even though we're not getting
perfect 60 so I do see it dipping down
51 right there is the lowest that I saw
oh come on
even though it dipped down to 51 it
still seemed relatively smooth that
performance was I think because the
processor just does so well
65 fps really impressive I might
actually try to turn up the settings
just a little bit all right I want to
pause real quick because we just got in
our max tech design t-shirts as you guys
can see we have Apple product pattern
right here we've got like the Apple
watch we've got the home pod the iMac
we've got the Mac Pro the Pro display
XDR the iPhone pretty cool design right
here and we did this because we're
celebrating finally reaching 300k
subscribers so thank you guys for all
the support and if you want to continue
to support us you can find our emerge
shelf right below this video we have a
few different designs and we're actually
coming out with a full all over Apple
product design really soon so thank you
guys for supporting us and let's get
back into the game we're dropping right
on this dude see that FPS dropped down
to like 46 at one point but that was
just for a tad bit when I was dropping
down I needed a alright so the frame
rates were not hitting 60fps all the
time at a minimum they were dipping down
to probably an average about 50 55 so
that's not perfect but I do want to test
if I can raise the textures up too high
oh come on are you kidding so I am
seeing the frame rates between 56
and like 43 at times so it's definitely
not perfect so just going to high on the
textures really did impact the FPS and
now I'm starting to feel it not being
very smooth I'm starting to feel more
kind of stutter in that coil noise it's
starting to get a little bit annoying so
I am gonna go back just for fun instead
of normal let's actually go to low
actually very low let's turn it all the
way down I am still seeing it going down
to 51 48 it's honestly not helping that
much 61 FPS got him honestly there does
not seem to be a very big difference
between what I had before which has both
of those settings are normal now that
it's on low and very low I am not seeing
FPS that much higher it's about the same
6061 right now no real difference and
now I can tell that the textures suck
like look at the ground if we're not gay
gaining much FPS it's not really worth
it alright so after testing now I think
we can finally settle on normal for the
texture and normal for the texture
filters got him gaudium look at that 69
FPS right now 67 it's hitting pretty
good FPS 74 even oh alright as I moved
away
well I just got owned so there you guys
have it hopefully you guys enjoyed that
gameplay so let's answer the original
question of this video is the 2020 razor
blade stealth a good gaming laptop I'd
say definitely yes you get really decent
FPS close to about 60 FPS average and it
feels pretty smooth gaming especially in
war zone but the biggest deal is that
this is also a portable laptop it's got
a great design great keyboard pretty
decent trackpad great display so it's
basically at the level of MacBook Pro
quality but you can also do some gaming
with that really nice 1650 ti max q
graphics cards so hopefully you guys
enjoyed this video if you did go ahead
and tap the like button below
click the circle above to subscribe and
definitely look below this video at our
merch shelf for our new t-shirts if you
guys want to support us and check out
one of those two videos right over there
especially the one where we compared it
to the MacBook Pro thanks for watching
and we'll see you in the next video
[Music]